hello and thank you for joining us for
this
agilent technology cell analysis webinar
series
my name is ian hayes i'm the director of
marketing communications for the
seahorse xf product line within the cell
analysis division at agilent
i'll be your host for today's webinar
before i introduce our speaker today
allow me to share a bit about agilent
technologies and the products we offer
for some analysis
agilent is a trusted leader in life
sciences clinical research diagnostics
and applied chemical markets
providing laboratories with instruments
services consumables
applications and expertise to enable our
customers to gain the insights they seek
adjuncts rapidly growing set analysis
portfolio enables deeper more
reliable insight across a variety of
same analysis applications
where investigators and drug developers
seek to understand complex cellular
environments
and interactions i'm delighted to
introduce today's speaker dr victor
daly osmar associate dean for research
and endowed professor
in mitochondrial medicine and pathology
from uab
university of alabama at birmingham
today victoria presents on the
fascinating subject of defining
bioenergetic metabolite interactome
in human subjects this is a new concept
which describes how defining our
bioenergetic health
at the level of individual cells can now
be achieved
victor received his phd at the
university of ethics in england
and then moved to the university of
oregon as a postdoctoral fellow to
pursue his interests in the structure
and function of mitochondrial proteins
in human disease after a period as a
lecturer in japan and 10 years as a
research scientist
he burrows welcome in london he joined
uab to establish his own research group
in the department of pathology in 1995.
his research program has been
instrumental in defining how redox
biology
modifies mitochondrial function in
pathology and in recognition of these
achievements
he was awarded a lifetime achievement
award by the society for free radical
biology and medicine
in 2012. he has been continuously funded
by the nih
for 24 years and has published over 350
articles
with an age factor of over 100 and over
37 000 citations
at uab his contribution to research in
mitochondrial pathology
was recognized by his appointment as the
foundation faculty for the entire
professorship in mitochondrial medicine
and pathology
he's now developing a program to apply
measures of bioenergetic health and
metabolism to personalized medicine
before i hand over the mic to victor i'd
like to remind you that this webinar is
interactive
and that there will be a question and
answer period immediately following the
talk
you'll notice on your screen that you
can and in fact should
type in your questions during the
presentation and this helps to ensure
that we get to as many of your questions
as possible
with that thank you victor for joining
us today please take it away
thank you and thank you for the
opportunity for
talk to you all in this uh socially
distant and
difficult time what i'm going to discuss
with you
is some ideas about how we link together
metabolism with bioenergetics and how
that changes in
populations of people so
we're used to the idea of thinking of
metabolism as an integrated network and
of course i've put this slide because of
my i haven't been back to england now
for months and i usually go back
at least two three times a year so this
is the london underground
and of course the stations you can think
of
as the enzymes and then the trains of
the metabolites
and it's obvious then that this is a
network
and if you want to get from one place in
the network to another
in many cases there are lots of
alternatives so
it's adaptive and plastic and this is
what makes
uh doing metabolism research
so challenging so
plasticity means there are alternative
routes to achieve the same destination
and this is where the heart of the
biology and the response to normal
physiology and pathology life
and of course in this picture people
have taken the similar sort of ideas
of a subway map as a
metabolic map here is in the middle
there you can see the tca
cycle for example now
the we used to think i mean when people
started
studying metabolism many years ago that
cancer cells
were the cells which were the archetype
for metabolic plasticity
and of course that's because that's a
warburg effect where you can switch
between
aerobic glycolysis and aerobic
metabolism
but it turns out that while we have
mitochondria essential to all of this
network
this switch then between aero to aerobic
glycolysis is a feature of a lot of
different cells
that we didn't know about before and
it's only because we've had new
technologies such as the seahorse
platform
to look at these that we can now look at
t-cells for example aerobic glycolysis
is a
key part of their function macrophages
they have a unique metabolic fingerprint
for every one of the different kinds of
micropages
fibrosis in order for the cell to become
fibrosis tgfb to
derive drives a metabolic switch to
aerobic glycolysis
and platelets they have an on-demand
switch which i'm going to show you into
strong aerobic glycolysis
now it turns out that measuring
um metabolism in the platform like uh
such as the seahorse has been thought
about for a long time and it's a kind of
a
biochemical quirk there's only really
one enzyme that uses most of the
oxygen in your body and that's the
enzyme in the mitochondria
called cytochrome c oxidase and that is
interestingly
rarely limiting for mitochondrial
metabolism so that means that measuring
oxygen consumption is as a readout
or a insight into the whole of
mitochondrial metabolism several hundred
enzymes
similarly glycolysis changing ph
but glycolysis changes ph but there are
other things of course that change ph2
but measuring changes in ph can give us
some insight into
glycolysis as well so
we're fortunate really this quirk of
nature that
these two parameters which are fairly
straightforward to measuring with
precision
can give us insight into metabolism
so here is a typical sort of plot that
you get from the
sea horse platform you've got a oxygen
consumption
rate that's the rate at which you're
using oxygen
and then with time so there is a basal
stable
signal and that represents that little
cartoon at the top
is the sort of simplified proton circuit
where you get protons being pumped using
oxygen they come back into the
mitochondria
to then actually make atp
and you can do this different ways and
if you're using
cell energetics then you're using the
fuels that the cell can
obtain or make itself if you block with
oligomytin you stop that ability to make
atp
and the oxygen consumption must go down
and the proportion it goes down and then
proportions the amount you make atp
now you have a bit left over which is
called
well we call it proton leak but really
it's any movement of ions which is not
linked
through or coupled to atp synthesis
now we can short circuit or override
the oligomycin block by a non-coupler
like fccp and now oligomytin is not
doing anything
more so that gives you an idea of the
maximal respiration which
cell fuels can achieve
and it then gives you some sense of the
maximum capacity of the mitochondria
now not everything in the cell that uses
oxygen is mitochondria so antimycinate
we can use that it knocks out the
mitochondrial and what you're left with
is what we call non-mitochondrial now
probably we should never have called it
out because it can be
some enzyme which are mitochondrial in
fact but
what we mean is non-cytochrome oxidase
now you'll notice that the basal level
is substantially lower than the maximal
level
and we call that the reserve capacity
and that's a key concept in a lot of
metabolic ideas or signaling pathways is
that
there is a much greater capacity of a
pathway of basal conditions which can be
called upon
on biological need and that actually is
going to become an important feature of
how
understanding how energetic changes with
pathology
and of course even if the reserve
capacity
decreases as long as it's somewhat
higher than basal
then it means that physiologically we
can function
but how we function then the way the
basal metabolism working is not going to
be the same
so this means in principle if you follow
this thinking
that the basal metabolism can predict
the response
to subsequent stresses so where your
basal metabolism sits
will determine how you function under
stress or
under demand and this idea then
is captured in this picture and where it
says the total mitochondrial strategy
and then the pathological stress and
then this reserve capacity i'm going to
show you this in another picture so you
can see it better
so we can get this read out of both
glycolysis and oxidative phosphorylation
and at the top is an experiment with
the oxygen consumption rate and then
at the bottom the corresponding
glycolysis and you can see it's a very
very stable signal
still you add the oligomycin the fccp
and the antimyosin
and 2dg we add 2dg to inhibit glycolysis
the little cartoon on the right is from
one of our papers the 2012 biological
chemistry paper
where we go through all the different or
what we could think of at the time
all the different interpretations of
whether these things change and what
does it mean
so if you're interested in that please
take a look
now this is then actually starts to
raise an interesting point it says
the metabolism then at the basal state
should reflect the individual
bioenergetics
and if that is a population of cells
like in cell culture where there's
a lot of they're really quite
homogeneous
then that should be true but
interestingly
if you take the metabolism from
different people
then that variation should inherently be
reflected in variations in the
metabolism
and what i'm going to show you has a
exploration of that old idea
leads to the concept of an interaction
between
metabolism and energetics
so we've been interested in doing
translational
bioenergetics for the last few years
and to do that we wanted to
develop the methods that we have for
blood
samples of which could be used by
energetically from
isolated from blood and this is
useful because it's regarded as being
non-invasive
um i ex all of the
blood cells which have mitochondria are
exposed to the soil factors of
circulation
they interact with organs and tissues in
the body
and the response to the changes in their
physiology and pathology and of course
they have their own functions for
example in
inflammation so this is
raising the concept that
our responses energetically are a system
response or a whole body
response uh not just related to
a specific organ and i'm going to talk
to you about what the evidence for that
is
so from a blood sample we can get
and purify to a high degree of
specificity monocytes so let me tell you
what this is
it this is a energy map and
this is the oxygen consumption rate on
the uh y-axis
and the uh e-car on the
extra cellular cellular acidification
rate on the x-axis
and i'm going to show you where each of
the cells from the
blood line so monocytes are
quite got high glycolysis and high
oxidative phos neutrophils
and mitochondria but they're not
metabolically that active
uh lymphocytes are have a more aerobic
metabolism in their resting state
and then platelets are somewhere in the
middle but this is quite nice you
have within one blood sample
cells which represent a very diverse
range of energetic programs
so pbmcs which some people use are a
mixed population with different
metabolic programs so
if you use them you you can but then
you're going to get a weighted average
of whatever the pbmc population is
so there is a caveat with
just using pbmcs so
okay we can easily isolate the cells and
we can
we have shown in our previous
publications that we can
readily measure energetics in those but
can blood derived cells serve as a
surrogate for other
tissues so there is a way of thinking
that says if you want to understand
muscle metabolism you better make a
muscle biopsy
but while there is
value in doing that that is not a
practical process for large populations
or actually monitoring people over time
so this is data from through sri shiva's
lab
who's done some pioneering work with
using platelets
and she looked at 32 uh
older individuals 86 to 93
and she compared permeability muscle
fibers
the platelets and the phosphorus nmr
and there's the paper references there
i'm just going to show you a snapshot of
the data
this is the platelet-based low-carb
correlated with the muscle atp
synthesis and you can see that's quite a
strong relationship there
here is platelet atp linked ocar that's
after oligomycin again a very strong
relationship highly significant
and this is the proton leak again which
is connected
and the maximum low carb so what you can
see from this
is that in fact in this patient
population group
there is a strong relationship between
platelet energetics and muscle
energetics
and that changes and is different
between individuals
and let's have a look at the top right
one if you look at the
person each one of those dots is a
different person
if you look at the lowest one then it's
about
uh 50ish 40 ish and if you look at the
highest one it goes up to about 100 120.
so that means there is a threefold
difference in the efficiency of
mitochondria between
people and these people are all
nominally healthy
so they're all functioning fine so that
means there are going to be differences
in the metabolism
and i'm going to explore that idea with
you
so the platelet is a really quite
nice metabolic sensor it's exposed to
the soluble factors of circulation just
like the other cells
you can do energetics and metabolomics
on the same sample
and as i've just shown you it's highly
correlated with muscle function in
humans
so you can isolate the platelets from
platelet-rich plasma very easily it's a
very straightforward
method and we published that and you can
see if you like
or you can take platelets from a
platelet donor
back and that's the advantage of that is
you're not limited by number so
it's very good to work out different
methodologies and we worked out the
metabolomics and the energetics in the
donor samples so here is
coming back to this concept of
bioenergetic health
and bioenergetic health is on the y-axis
here
and unhealthy all the pathologies on the
x-axis and you can see the dot there at
the top
shows you here they're starting off at
the
beginning there so if we increase atp
demand
then we use up some of that reserve
capacity that's a concept
you're all familiar with
now in addition to the idea of
responding to
actual energy demand there is also a
role for mitochondria in lots of other
functions
so where you sit on this curve is
determined by your genetics
and if for example you have
a uh infection you lose some of that
reserve capacity
and although you're still you're not in
the red zone you'll still be able to
function then
we all know for example well it
unfortunately with covid this
is a classic example of dramatic effects
in
some people on their ability for
their success acceptability to figure
fatigue and soul
and of course if you then have a
concomitant treatment with a therapy
that can knock you down below the thing
and then you're in crisis
so we really want to understand
what is controlling the movement along
that curve in
reserve capacity and what pushes things
into crisis
and of course our previous many years of
doing research is
very very and fixated on the idea of
bioenergetic dysfunction
and the basic definition of that is
anything i have which is lower than the
control i'm going to call a dysfunction
but in reality if you look at that
reserve capacity
curve you can be at any place on that
curve and it's not dysfunction at all
so we have to actually start to think
about a different way of defining what
bioenergetic dysfunction really means
and of course
different people lie on that curve and
then perfectly healthy state
um and we and then not one is not
necessarily more dysfunctional than the
other
so let's have a closer look at platelet
metabolism
this is the platelet okay on the top
left
um the eco on the bottom left with the
injection of thrombin which makes the
platelets aggregate
and you can see the oh car there's a
stimulation there
we add antimycin and it goes down
to the basal level and what that tells
you is that
this stimulation of ocaris actually
uh mitochondrial and not cyclooxygenase
or something like that factor originates
is happening but the amounts of oxygen
consumed are small relative to
mitochondria
and thrombin you can see that is a
fantastically big
increase in glycolysis there and what
there are two cell types where we've
seen these
massive increase one on neutrophils
which have an nadph
oxidase which is activated uh in
inflammation and the other is platelets
where in aggregation
they pull upon both oxfals and
um glycolysis so that's shown here
you have this massive switch to aerobic
glycolysis and in our papers we've shown
that in fact you need both
so that is the profile that we're seeing
there that is the typical profile and
we can routinely achieve that in
platelet samples
now we have done a limited amount of
work with people with
known inherited metabolic diseases
and here is a sample with somebody with
complex one and two defects
and you can see that the basal ocar
is decreased the atp linked
and the maximal but the reserve capacity
is maintained
so this fits the clinical profile of
these type of
patients who can have
can be functional to degree but under
stress uh fatigue or other
problems arise and we can actually also
measure in the same sample the
respiratory complexes by permeabilizing
the outer membrane
and we can show them that depicted
complex one two and in this case also
complex four
so from a human platelet sample we can
start to see
differences and some pathological
differences in mitochondrial function
we can now start there with the
collaboration
led by uh foreign
in ucla they have developed the methods
to actually do
uh mitochondrial function on frozen
samples
and we show the data where we
collaborated with them where you can
show it with
a platelet so you can measure complex
activities in pressure pros and plates
this is very important because then this
raises the possibility
of looking at bank tissues and
transporting tissues across the country
which has been a limitation before if
you're only restricted to fresh
samples so
this picture on the left is now i've
shown you a few times in different ways
is the mitochondrial stress test as it's
sometimes called
and that actually then
we've done that now in 50 60 cells
and it turns out it is a bioenergetic
program
so that shape if you like all the
relative amounts of those different
factors in that bioenergetic profile
tell you something about the adaptation
of a particular cell
to metabolism so this is
data from different individuals with
on the top right with uh platelets from
different individuals
and you can see that the atp length is
well correlated to the basal
reserve capacity is well correlated
versus maximal and basal versus maximal
is also uh correlated but basal versus
non-mitochondrial is not connected at
all
so what that means is that there is an
internal compensation mechanism
working on the genetic program that your
mitochondria gives you
to make sure that you can meet the
energetic demands of the platelet
so we are all um
then have this inbuilt system to set up
a bio and adjective program which is
healthy
so if you look at the top right for a
minute at the bottom where it's about 25
and then at the top where it's about 80
or so what it means is
there is this almost three to four fold
difference
in the bioenergetic program from
different people
even though that they're serving exactly
the same
physiological function and that means
that the metabolism
in the bottom the person at the bottom
of that curve and the person at the top
must be very different in their basal
state
so this is with a study with
over 90 different individuals and each
dot is a different
person and these are all platelets so
you can look at that and you say this is
the basal
distribution of the basal atp link to
maxwell and you could say well
this is just noise in the system but
actually if you look at the proton leak
and non-mitochondrial reserve capacity
the variance is very different
so then that again reinforces the idea
that
this variation is biology
and not all of it is to do with this
noise in the system and we can
disentangle those two things
and here you know you can see that that
variance is very different
so using standard uh statistical
techniques then we can do
a multivariate analysis of each
factor so basal at the top
is each dot there is a person
and then it's the correlation
based on an atp linked is perfectly
correlated
and that's telling you that
the whole system is set up to provide
the base of metabolism to give the atp
demand that you need to have
and that is a completely predictable
process
even though it's different between
different people
it's predictable so in other words if i
know your basal
i can tell you what your atp linked is
going to be with like a 95
confidence and that shows all of the
the whole set of the data here and
i've just highlighted the couple so
here is on the top left atp link that is
a correlation
which if you were doing a protein assay
and your student did that you'd be very
happy so it's a perfect correlation
and then the proton leak versus baseball
much variable more variable so that
means proton leak is changing
independently
to a much greater extent than atp length
is
and then maximal versus bottle is
changed that means the reserve capacity
is being kept constant so if mat basal
goes up maximal goes up with it
so the reserve capacities get more
constant
so this is telling us that there is
a bioenergetic program which is
established
between people so
if you look at the the curve here the
arrows show people
at different places so the atp if the
atp adp is the same which it must be
because the platelets are functioning
exactly the same as far as we can tell
then there must be a two-to-fold
difference in efficiency and that must
mean
there's a difference in the flux through
the tga cycle
now this is a study again from shooters
group
which shows a
group of patients with sickle cell
disease and so the concept would be
that in sickle cell disease then there
will be a difference in this program
and the paper the data she published uh
initially
shows that the base as you'd
would predict from that the classical
way of looking at it is that the basal
metabolism is decreased in the sickle
cell disease
and that is related also to the
decreasing complex five activity
now if you do this multivariate analysis
with
the the same patients now you can see
that in fact
the capacity is the top left which is
telling you the efficiency the
efficiency hasn't changed
but the total capacities change because
of the loss of the complex 5 activity
so the red ones are the sickle cell and
the blue ones of the
control they're really on the same cut
you've just got less
overall complex five but in the other
one the basal versus the maximal
then there is a loss of a relationship
and maximum versus atp there's a loss of
relationship
and the proton leak has changed so
you've got
that you're dealing with a much
different relationship between proton
leak and basal
so this leads to this idea that
the bioenergetic dysfunction if you like
is not just defined by
difference in an absolute value of a
particular enzyme
but how this program is itself put
together
so if that's true then the metabolome of
these people should be different
so let's see we did the experiment to
see if that's true
so we took platelets and we used
oligomytin so as a
this is a test case so oligomycin
binds the atp synthase very specific way
knocks out it knocks it out and so we
you and it runs the cell to exhaustion
it forces the cell to rely on
glycolysis so we took cells we extracted
them
treated them with oligometer and
extracted them and then in collaboration
with our friends in emery
we did the untargeting metabolomics
here is the heat map and this is with 12
different platelet samples
and you can see grape then
the heat maps are totally different so
while the combination does work
now if we do the pathway analysis then
for example we see glycolysis is one of
the things that's changed dramatically
and de novo fatty acids too so those are
things that
we really expected so this is our proof
of principle if you like
now let me go back a second
um i wanted to make a point here is that
they measured over three and a half
thousand different metabolites but in
that heat map
only 150 so are showing differences
so that's important because if
everything was showing a difference then
it would be some kind of artifact
and it shows there is some discreteness
in how
metabolism is changing in response to
stress
this is like blocking one of those
closing one of those stations on the sub
on the subway line and the metabolites
go through a different part
now to do this we you to take this to a
different level we used a technique they
have developed called xm wasp
and this allows you to on the left top
left there plot
any parameter from the uh bioenergetic
profile mitochondrial stress test with
any of the metabolites and that's a
fatty acid there
and if we do that the maximum occur
right of lyso phosphate methanolamine
which is there
correlates very well
with the metabolite abundance and it
makes biochemical sense because the
fatty acid is
more efficient so the
maximum low car goes down so what i'm
going to show you though
is how we did this uh three and a half
thousand times six times so the
bioenergetic parameters are going to be
the boxes and the metabolites the
circles
so we've got three thousand metabolic
features and six mitochondrial stress
tests and we have a stringency for a
correlation coefficient of 0.5 and a
probability of greater than 0.05
so we're now going to do that exact
mathematical thing
thousands of times and then we get this
beautiful picture here
which is the bioenergetic metabolite
interactor
so let's go again carefully through what
this is we've got
the squares or boxes which are
the mitochondrial stress test parameters
so we got reserved capacity at the top
left there
and we've got all of the metabolites
that are correlated with it negatively
or positively
blue is positive red is negative lines
the edges
make a community so you've got a
community there
you can see that very nicely the next
thing down is my
maximal so maximum is correlated with
reserve capacity
and then you have a community too and
there are some shared
metabolites between them then you have
atp
linked and basalt which is strongly in
in the same community because we showed
they were perfectly correlated
then you have non-mitochondrial proton
leak which are in a fourth community
which are much less connected than any
of the other things
now this is unsupervised so
we gave no information about the
mitochondrial stress test here
so this is amazing really just from the
basal metabolism
metabolic metabolism we have predicted
the mitochondrial stress test profile
because the strength of the correlation
coefficients are exactly the same in
these communities that is
it's showing you there as they are in
the
um analysis i showed you with
80 people with just the mitochondrial
stress test
so this is now saying something very
interesting it's saying
your base on the table predicts the
response you're going to have
to any energy demand now
of course there's an interesting thing
here there are a lot more they're about
150
metabolites in that uh picture there
which is quite a lot more than we
expected and we know we would have
guessed what some of them were
for example but such as fatty acids
but there are much more and this is this
pie chart here
shows the distribution of these and so
there are icosa noise makes sense amino
acids make sense carbohydrates fatty
acids make sense so the top
quadrant right quadratic that makes
total sense
we are absolutely staggered though to
see
40 percent of xenobiotics which means
they are not metabolized of human
origin or natural products so over 60
percent
of the things correlated with
metabolism bioenergetics in human
populations
are not coming from the human metabolism
and of course they can be coming from
microbiome they can be coming from our
diet
and they come from the environment
and here's an example which is a bit
this upsetting actually this is a
product which is used in food
preservatives and the plasticizer and so
on dilaural thyroid
appropriate and as you can see it's
inhibiting
atp length respiration so it's behaving
somewhat like oligomycin so
we have lots of things in in our
environment which are changing our
metabolism
so as a food as a sort of proof of
principle
about how this prediction is
that the bioenergetic metabolite
interactive
or the bemi will change with toxicity so
we
exposed you know to ships tests with
this
true to doxorubicin which is a
well-known cancer chemotherapeutic
and it has lots it's pretty used pretty
widely
and it also is
associated with cardiotoxicity that's a
dose limiting
aspect of its therapy so we treated
platelets with it did the mitochondrial
stress test
with different amounts of uh dots
rubicin and the metabolomics
and the idea is now that the bearing
will be totally different
so here is that classical way of looking
at the
data we have the oxygen consumption rate
basal
ap maximal the top one's maximum you can
see
with increasing concentrations of
doxorubicin it progresses dead
aggressively and of course if we do the
classical way of analysis the atp link
to
car in the top right is decreased
and um so it's behaving as it would in
the way we normally analyze an
experiment
but now if we look at the different
individuals these are from all different
individuals
then how each individual is responding
is not the same
so these the number each number there is
an individual
and the color is specific for each
individual
and you can see that where that
bar the black bar lies is not the same
in the two graphs
that's sort of indicating to us that
there are different responses between
people now if we do the multivariate
analysis
you can see what's happening is both
whether you have docs there or not
the total capacity to make atp is
suppressed
but the line is pretty much the
correlation is pretty much the same
so what mitochondria are there are
working as best they can that means a
bit like the sickle cell
example the maximum
burst reverse capacity that program has
gone
right so we've lost that program
and if we do the unsupervised heat map
then you can see
that there is a strong difference on the
principal component analysis
the metabolites when we do the
untargeted metabolomics
show that there's quite a big difference
but you notice that although
there is no problem separating the
um vehicle from the docks treated
the actual variation within the docks
treated
is quite high as it is in the vehicle
that
is due to this difference in individuals
so here is the bemi with and the control
where that connection the connection is
and what we're predicting is
it will change dramatically with the
doctor rupert
and you can see that here the
communities have changed and their
relationships changed
atp linkedin basel is still there and
you saw that correlation
was still existing but now maximal
has collapsed into basal and reserve
capacity
diminished completely so this is showing
us how we can use this
use this sort of strategy
to understand the response to stress and
for example one
idea might be to take a population of
people who are going to get
treatment with doctor dr uberton take
their platelets before and after
and then relate that to the incidence of
the cardiac complications and ask the
question
can they platelet demi predict the
complications with docs there are other
ways of showing this
this is a bubble plot and what it means
is the color is
means that it's significant and then the
size of it
means there's more metabolites so the
bigger the bubble is
then the more significant it is so
if the vehicle one you can see fatty
acid oxidation and reserve capacity has
a nice strong bubble and we knew that
from our other studies
right and so that is clear and when we
do the doxorubicin you can see
now we have a different set of
bubbles showing how the metabolic
profile
has changed so introducing the block at
several different
stations in the subway analogy it means
that now the trains are traveling
through different pathways
we've got some worrying mechanisms that
are in play now
this is saying that if you
have some of the uh toxic
agents from the environment in your
blood the response to doxorubicin
is not the same okay so this is telling
us that
doxorubicin then is potentially their
response to a
therapeutic is then influenced by
the diamond energetics chain being
changed by your environmental exposure
and we're picking up things like
benzodiazepines
and um azido spermadine
plant alkaloid right so
one of the the positive sides of this is
that in
environmental exposures when
similar individuals have been exposed to
not only the same environment
we can determine the degree of impact on
their bioenergetic programs
here's an example with
dihydrocrecumberine
an anticoagulant and rodenticide
and here on the left is the data from
the un
unsupervised uh metabolomics and on the
right
actually the authentic compound so you
can see that we can
reproduce effects on the reserve
capacity from
the treatment with the authentic
compound
so what i hopefully shown you is that
now
we are being using the techniques where
we can start to
integrate metabolomics into programs
where we're not forced to look at the
changes in
a fingerprint or diagnostic
single metabolite but how the programs
are changing in response to stress
stress and how this can also help us
understand
which responses are adaptive and which
are
maladaptive leading to problems
uh so it's early days and there's a lot
more work to be done
but hopefully this has given you some
ideas about how we can
look at metabolism in bioenergetics in
an integrated way in human populations
or in fact any other populations um
i'll just leave you with this nostalgic
uh
reminder it's about the journey and mind
the gap
those who have been to london will get
that joke others will not
so and finally i just want to
acknowledge
all the people who've contributed to
this huge amount of work
uh especially the group in emery led by
dean jones and young me
and ryan um karen who did that working
with shruti
and valerie on metabolism has been uh
on platelets and metabolism has been
great
and uh the numerous people in the group
particularly value gloria and
uh michelle who uh developed these
different techniques that
we're currently using uh
thank you for your attention and i'm
happy to ask any question answer
any questions as best i can
well thank you very much victor i have
to say on a personal level that was one
of the most insightful and fascinating
uh presentations i've seen in a long
while that i really thoroughly enjoyed
that
um for everybody in the audience uh
we'll now start the question and answer
portion of the webinar
uh if you have a question you'd like to
ask please submit it now uh we'll be
able to get to uh
certainly a good few questions before
the end of the hour um however if we
don't mention it to your question
we'll be forwarding all of them on to
victor and the agilent team to follow up
with you
additionally i just want to point out if
you'd like to learn anything more about
the solutions we offer for cell analysis
you'll see on your screen that there are
some links on the bottom left section of
your screen that you can follow
under the resource list one thing in
particular i wanted to
just draw your attention to is that we
have launched a brand new
an interactive drug discovery target
identification and target validation
ebook it's a very nice resource it
covers
a number of different disease areas and
i would certainly
recommend it to you for for a look
um so let's get started so victor i've
got um
just one quite broad question of my own
and then i'll start with
some of the questions from the audience
um
just your your own sense of the
scope and potential for this new
um technique this new representation the
combination of
the bioenergetics and the metabolome
from a therapeutic perspective from the
you know the clinical implications and
scope of this for personalized medicine
i'd just be interested if you could just
share some of your thoughts as to
to how broad you see at the application
of this
um well a lot of us in the community are
doing these experiments where we're
taking
samples and measuring metabolomics or
energetics from as many as 30 or 40
people
what i'm proposing here is that
those studies and we've got all the
technologies there as i've shown you to
do this
we can approach the analysis of this
to understand these relationships in a
different way
and then that throws up new
insights into what's going wrong why are
some people more susceptible than others
what therapies might work or not work so
for example
we have an enormous number of very safe
pharmaceuticals and drugs which work
through
energetic so one that of course
everybody knows about is metformin for
example
but how do we know if somebody's going
to respond to metformin or not it's not
without its side effects
and this is an approach to that another
issue is that a lot of drugs have
so-called off-target effects on
mitochondrial function
some people may be that doxorubicin
would be one of those examples
some people may be quite resistant to
that
but some people may be very sensitive so
it provides a a new and uh
tool for precision medicine on
personalized metals
well i guess i'd take from that that you
would see that at least in the
investigative phase it would have quite
broad
application um broader opportunity
i mean a lot of things out there already
you know so people can take data they've
already got
and try the analysis this way so i
i would encourage everybody to do the
very minimum if you've done an
energetics analysis on
30 odd people then do that multivariate
analysis
i guarantee you you'll get a different
insight onto how
your patient population is behaving than
if you do
a sort of is the proton leaked
significantly different
style of analysis
that's a that's a very very interesting
point and a good segue to
to my next question um you presented a
lot of
data on on fresh platelets you get some
mention of the fact that
it was possible to do these measurements
on frozen platelets as well
um what it what is this what is the
scope of that in terms of people being
able to do retrospective studies on
on stored samples and things what sort
of correlation do you get between
fresh and frozen and you know how how
far can you push that with this type of
analysis
yeah there are a few quite nice smallish
studies
looking at the impact of froze freezing
on the intact cells
and how they recover and we've done a
little bit ourselves you can
resurrect or resuscitate if you like
the cells which have been previously
frozen
it does change the energetics but
in a subtle way so it is possible i
think
the thing you can do on the frozen
sample without too much problem is
measure the activity of electron
transport complexes
but you're not going to be able to
really use that then to correlate that
effectively with the energetics because
of the whole cell the energetics of the
whole cell is integrating hundreds of
pathways and that's why
probably is connected to hundreds of
metabolites
and you know of the different blood cell
types
um victor what what do you think of the
most appropriate blood types to
to use in in a clinical study
that's a good question um each of them
have got their strengths and weaknesses
obviously if you have an interesting
t-cell biology then that's the group you
get that's the one you focus on so
that's a straightforward answer
as a surrogate generalized marker
i think truthy shiva has shown quite
clearly that the platelets are among the
most reproducible to generate
and easiest to prepare
reproducibly with the smallest amount of
blood sample
so monocytes then require
antibodies and columns and things to
prepare and we published all those
techniques
so if you're getting into this or in the
in this early stages of this kind of
research
i think platelets are probably if you
haven't done it before might be the area
to focus on
so i'm with a number of questions as
well in terms of
both your study but in terms of the the
broader possibility you know
around diet and also around age as well
so one question here was was the blood
drawn
during fasting um you know can diets
immediate changes in diet versus chronic
affects the results and in the same
context i suppose
um you know what do you see or what have
you seen in terms of
the effect of aging on that relationship
between the bioenergetic and metabolism
profiles
okay there's several questions in there
so i'll um
sorry yeah yeah no no i'll just unbundle
it a bit so
the weed in the study i
showed you then we had a fasting blood
draw with a healthy volunteer
so we we did control that
the there is a nice study by um
which shows that uh
oxalate in the diet can change
monocyte uh function that's by tunisia
mitchell at
uab so and i've shown you
also with our data that things in diet
and the environment do have an
effect um
so if you take um
and then aging it the data is
quite good so the the data from tony
molina there's data from
uh shooting shiva there's data um
with the patients who neurodegenerative
deeds from russ swerdlow
are basically showing that
that if you have healthy aging the
energetic profiles
and metabolic profiles pretty much fit
on the same curves as other people so
that
oldest we went to at 60 odd and we
didn't see any differences
truth has gone to 80 plus as i showed
you and there are some differences but
the idea is that the the energetic
program
becomes less plastic as you get older
and that seems to be what we're seeing
um it then becomes
important as with any study to
clearly stratify the parameters between
what the healthy group is and what your
group of in
subjects of interest are
thank you victor um another question
here
um are are by other bioenergetic
approaches applied to patients with you
know can they be applied only to
patients with kind of existing diseases
you think
or um do you do you anticipate a
potential prognostic
uh application here for uh predisposal
to diseases or even prior to a disease
onset
what what a very good question nice
question what
what what our data seems to be showing
is
that quite clearly between
a population of nominally healthy people
the bioenergetic and the demi the
bioenergetic
metabolite interaction it varies now it
follows from that
which something we already know is that
people's susceptibility to
different diseases is not the same
people's susceptibility to
cardiovascular disease or hypertension
is not the same
so this then raises the possibility that
if energetics contributes to that
it could be a predictive factor so for
example
the factors which take lipid profiles
and predict your risk for heart disease
um are now very sophisticated
and have a high degree of prognostic
potential
but they don't predict they give their
statistical prediction and perhaps the
energetics could
our basic bioenergetic profile could
also fit into that
type of analysis
so um victor we're coming close to the
hour
so i'm going to pose a last question
um before i i thank you
and conclude the presentation
um got a couple of questions really
relating to
i suppose quantification and statistics
and
power of these types of experiments so i
kind of bundle these together and
you can answer them as as best you see
fit
um are these metabolites that you study
are they
are they quantitatively comparable
among samples and also i i was kind of
interested to know
you know to get meaningful data from
these studies from a statistical point
of view
um how many subjects you know would you
need to study
for you know would you need it in a
human study to to have meaningful data
well if you're doing the energetics on
its own uh
you need our experiences you need
somewhere between 30 or 40 subjects
to compare
i think your analysis is important so
it's important not to take ratios of
things so for example if you normalize
everything to basel or something you're
throwing all of that
information away and you're you're
suppressing some of the biology
um the the precision with which you
count the cells load the plates and
things all those things matter they're
all technical matters that you
have to actually address when you set up
the experiments
uh with the when you add the metabolomic
data to it the n numbers go down
quite a lot because you're adding
several dimensions
to the data set the richness of the data
set
and so the statistical power increases
so like with all these studies
that it's important to culture a
friendly statistician
who can get engaged in the work you're
doing their their contribution is
invaluable
thank you i think there's a kind of a
wise advice and a
nice way to conclude the presentation
um i personally can think of so many
different ideas and applications and
things for
for that technique um i look forward to
to catching up with you afterwards
victor and thank you again for your
presentation
and thank you also to our really
excellent audience and
fantastic questions pose until next time
thank you everybody and goodbye for now
you